en 1981 après des années de lutte non
violente
les paysans du larzac obtiennent gagnent
cause le projet d'extension du camp
militaire est abandonné ce fut l'un des
bastions de la non-violence en france le
plateau du larzac dans l'aveyron pendant
dix ans entre 1971 et 1980 une menace
planait sur les paysans locaux
l'expropriation de leurs terres pour
l'extension d'un camp militaire pour
mener leur lutte les agriculteurs sont
part d'une arme nouvelle la non violence
c'est sûr que lorsqu'on veut faire une
action non violente on est obligé pour
prouver effectivement ça sa contestation
sur nos positions de rentrer ou de
remettre en question les lois donc de
faire de lille égalise
le principe de la non violence est
impulsée en inde par gandhi au début du
20e siècle
c'est d'ailleurs l'un de ses disciples
lanza del vasto qui initiera les paysans
larzacien à la lutte pacifique il fondé
en 1948 la communauté non violente de
l'arche à proximité du larzac la non
violence et la conversion de la colère
est d'abord il faut avoir quelque chose
à convertir bien entendu il faut avoir
un tempérament de guerrier pour pour
entrer dans la non violence avec
quelques efficace en 1972 en solidarité
avec les agriculteurs
lanza del vasto entamait une grève de la
faim de 15 jours
c'est un devoir de bon voisinage nous
habitons notre communauté est installé
dans les environs et nous considérons
que chez notre devoir d'intervenir
d'autres soutiendront aussi les 103
irréductibles paysans du larzac un
mélange inédit de militants de tous
horizons maoïste chrétiens écologistes
anti militariste tous conquis par la
lutte non violente
trente ans plus tard l'agriculteur
pierre burguière se souvenait
même des gens qui arrivent avec des
idées de violence des jeunes d'extrême
gauche ont accepté que la lutte du
larzac reste une lutte non violente a
été capitale
un combat pacifique qui portera ses
fruits en 1981 le président mitterrand
fraîchement élu annulait l'extension du
camp militaire
une victoire pour les paysans du larzac
qui continueront de véhicules et leurs
idéaux auprès notamment des
indépendantistes kanaks
aujourd'hui les paysans sont même
accusés d'avoir initié les kanaks à la
non violence
il vaut certainement mieux que le peuple
kanak viennent écouter ce qui peut se
dire on écoute et la non-violence du
larzac plutôt que les armes de kadhafi
jusqu'en 2001 des stages de formation à
la non-violence et est même proposée par
des paysans devenu militant
[Musique]
oh